sacred tiers are a vital resource in
eldon ring they're the way to level up
your flasks of tears and upgrade the
potency of the flasks making each chug
heal you for more hp or fp depending on
the flask you choose to use
so here is a guide on how to find all 12
sacred tiers that means that there will
be spoilers but i'll start with the
earlier areas of the lands between so
you can stop when you think i'm going
too far
not only that but i'll have timestamps
in the description so you can click off
if i mention an area you don't want to
hear about and with that let's begin
just south of limb grave is the weeping
peninsula this is meant to be the low
level area of the game and definitely
where you'll want to start out if you're
having trouble with stormville the
weeping peninsula also happens to have
three churches that contain sacred tiers
the first of these is the church of
pilgrimage which can be found on the
middle north side of the weeping
peninsula here on a map
just enter the church and pick up your
sacred tier
also on the weeping peninsula is the
fourth church america the religion of
america seems to have spread out from
its core closer to the archery as
evidenced by the naming of these and the
fourth church is all the way on the
outskirts of the weeping peninsula you
can find the 4th church america here on
a map on the far western side of the
weeping peninsula on the north side
as before just enter the church and pick
up your sacred tier
the kalu baptismal church is our final
destination on the weeping peninsula and
the most difficult of the weeping
peninsula's sacred tiers to get to find
it you'll have to head into the force at
the center of the weeping peninsula here
on a map
to get there start at the castlemore and
rampart site of grace and head west then
north and upwards until you find the
ailing village the alien village is
filled to the brim with frenzy inflicted
villagers and the kalu baptismal church
is filled with frenzy inflicted rats
take out the rats and the khalid
baptismal church's sacred tear is yours
for the taking
heading into limb crave and closer to
the earth tree we find the third church
of america as i said we're closer to the
start of america's religion the third
church of america can be found just
north of mistwood and in order to get
there you'll just have to head north
from the waypoint ruins cellar site of
grace where sorcerers selling in the mad
pumpkin head are located along the path
and then east of lake achill's bridge
head past the artist shack site of grace
and you'll end up at the church the
church is a vital find as it not only
has a sacred tier but also the flask of
wondrous physic a one-time use
customizable flask that recharges every
time you rest at a site of grace
heading north we reach leone of the
lakes just west of the first sight of
grace you'll find here the lake facing
cliff side of grace you'll find the
church of irith or here on a map
the church of earth houses the sorcerer
topes who will sell you sorceries after
paying him ten runes and hint to you the
way to enter the academy of real lucaria
the church of earth also happens to
house your fifth sacred tier
on the northeast side of lyria on the
way to the grand lift of dectus you'll
find the bellum church located right
here on a map
here you'll find your sixth sacred tier
the seventh sacred tier can be a little
more annoying to find but definitely
worth the hassle it's also located on
the northeast side of lyria here on a
map
in order to get to it you'll have to
wrap around northeast of bellum church
then east of the ground lift of dectus
and back south again on the way you'll
find the eye of sauron or a guard tower
that is regularly casting a madness
inflicting spell at the top
run past this and through the frenzied
flame village then up the cliff you'll
be invaded by festering fingerprint vike
beyond him is the church of inhibition
and finally the location of another
sacred tier
the next sacred tier will take us into
caled to the northeast side of the swamp
of aeonia you'll find celia town of
sorcery if you can solve the puzzle of
the town you'll be able to progress up
into the backstreets from here continue
up and south where you'll stumble upon
the church of the plague which is
located here on the map
that said you actually don't need to go
through celia to find the church of the
plague you can actually come from the
backside of dragon barrow here you'll
find your next sacred tier
for the next sacred tiers we'll need to
travel to a much steeper elevation and
onto the altus plateau pretty much
directly north of the altus highway
junction site of grace and further north
beyond the golden seed you can find
along the way you'll come across the
second church of america and your ninth
sacred tier the second church america
can be found here on the map
the second church of america isn't the
only church you'll be able to find in
the altus plateau that contains a sacred
tier this one is also near the altus
highway junction site of grace but while
technically closer it'll take you longer
to travel to as it's on the cliff near
this site of grace to get to this one
you'll have to use the warp at the
forest spanning grape bridge that warps
you to the north side of the broken down
bridge from there travel southeast along
the path where you'll eventually be able
to reach the rampart side path site of
grace head southwest from here and
you'll reach the stormcaller church and
your 10th sacred tier
traveling to an even higher altitude
you'll reach the mountaintops of the
giants this would also seem to be where
the teachings of america began for the
next secret tier can be found up here at
the first church of america to reach it
you'll need to get to the freezing lake
at the northeast peak of the map from
here either fight or skip the fight with
borealis of the freezing fog at the
southeast edge of the freezing lake
you'll find your 11th sacred tier within
the first church america located here on
the map
we come to the 12th and final sacred
tier also found at the mountaintops of
the giants this time you'll have to head
further south from the first church
america and into the flame peak once
you're close to the church the bloody
finger okinaw will invade you he's
guarding the church of repose and the
location of your final sacred tier
the church of repose can be found here
on the map
i hope this guide was helpful to you
we'll be updating our golden seed guide
to include every golden seed so make
sure to check that out as well as a
plethora of other elden ring content we
have readily available for you and in
the works and i'll see you guys next
time peace
you